in this lecture we focused most of our
attention on air pollution because that
is by far the most important way in
which the energy system impacts human
health today I'm going to talk to you
about some of the most important
airborne pollutants the so called
criteria air pollutants as defined by
the US Environmental Protection Agency
we can divide the list into two
categories direct pollutants and
secondary pollutants led nitrogen oxides
or NOx sulfur dioxide or Sox and carbon
monoxide are direct pollutants in that
they are emitted directly from
industrial activities primarily the
combustion of fossil fuels ozone is a
secondary air pollutant there is no
significant direct emission of ozone
instead ozone is formed in the
atmosphere when various other pollutants
most importantly NOx react in the
presence of sunlight particulate matter
falls into both categories some
particulate matter is emitted directly
think of the visible smoke one sees from
a diesel truck but other particulate
matter forms in the atmosphere from
chemical reactions such as those
involving NOx and Sox let's start with
the direct pollutants lead used to be
added to gasoline to improve combustion
in automotive engines a reduced
pre-ignition of the air fuel mixture
called NOC however lead is a potent
neurotoxin lead emissions from gasoline
reduce the IQ of children growing up in
polluted cities this was no minor effect
lead levels were high enough in the
1970s to reduce the average IQ of
Americans who grew up then by five
points lead pollution has been greatly
reduced to discouragement regulations
that banned its use in gasoline and
restricted use elsewhere across the
economy the average lead levels in
Americans blood has gone down by more
than a factor of 10 this is one of the
many examples where environmental
regulations have greatly improved human
welfare and have had a positive economic
benefit that greatly exceeded the direct
cost of imposing the regulation